happy mando monday is what we'll call
today i guess
mandalorian season 2 episode 1 breakdown
every star wars easter egg
and boba fett secret sighting revealed
from new
rock stars excited to check this out but
more excited to say that i finally
joined a community a very special
community i was at home goods
and uh christmas shopping on halloween
day actually
and then i found this doll i'm 30 years
old now it was the first time in my life
i was like i really
really want this doll and i was like
walking around the store looking at
other stuff
for like 30 40 minutes i was like but
it's a doll
i really want the doll and then i went
to go put it back and they were like
six before i picked up this one and then
all them were gone i was like
i think i really want this to happen and
then olivia bought the doll for me
because i clearly wanted it then i did
some more work that day and i had this
doll just resting on my lap for the past
hour i even slept with it this is all
true i've never had this experience
never slept with a doll before never
have i
always done and it's
like when you hold it and look at it it
just looks
it feels i i feel the feel i've never
had this
i'm being sincere i'm not even a funny
thing this is a great i'm so happy i'm
actually holding it
i'm jealous myself you look into its
eyes you're like wow
this feels something
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and the mandalorian is back on
disney plus
returning to tatooine to take down some
great dragons and true spoiler warning
resurrect one boba fett tomorrow sin in
the flesh
after reacting to the episode with tommy
on wikileaks i have now combed through
this episode and found
a ton of hidden star wars easter eggs
folks boba fett
is actually hiding in plain sight way
earlier in this episode let's talk about
the armor he's there i'm gonna fight
for you i'm gonna break it all down here
we go okay mando and baby pass pairs of
glowing red eyes from the hounds in the
shadows
there is some white arbesch that looks
like it translates to the word alderaan
maybe a memorial for the empire's go
crime
there's some more text down the center
that looks like no more for the
backwards
in the words you will learn to the right
of that
killer there also appeared to be how did
you get this out so fast
[Music]
in there interestingly one of them looks
like the wills those are the legendary
force beings that taught
many jedi how to come back as force
ghosts so gore koresh here is an
abyssian voice by john leguizamo they
watched some gomorian
fighting those are the race of jabba the
hutt's guards in return of the jedi
notice how their battle axes amid this
blue glow this could be based on nice of
the old republic game
in which the taurus arenas used a
similar shielding tech to reduce
lethality
mando has to take down he crushes guards
with his whistling birds and his vibro
blade they return from season one the
last guy he takes out is a zabrak
the same race as darwin i love how
mando's best star armor is itself an
offensive weapon like the first guy
punches him nearly breaks his own fist
then when he does that that's like what
happens
it's like oh man it has to do just stand
there while other people punch him into
each other
but before i continue i want to thank
bessie shoes for sponsoring this video
damn see that scene
getting your shout out out of the way so
early in the video
usually breathable too usually it's so
much later within
but they do let the air move out they
also have an anti-microbial insole to
keep your foot seams from getting
funkier than a mon calamari sauna hey
that's kind of me to mon calamari i'm
sure they smell fine
besties shoes are super stretchy just
look at them they fit like a sock and
they only weigh 175 grams they're also
made with this cool dynamics material
that keeps your feet warm in cold
weather
they give you a lot of talking points
eric yeah
really great to have besties for running
errands around town and keeping my feet
dry and warm and comfy even when i'm
trying to do too many things at once
while i'm skipping through people's
yards
let's get them through they cry swallow
them
[Music]
i spilled water all over my feetsy
wheatsies but my oinky oinkies are bound
dry
like they do see thanks bessie
shoes when you use my link in the
video's description oh one of the best
sponsorships ever
that was very comparable that was
amazing when you catch a scratch she
says i swear by the gatra
we could be referencing the droid gotra
which is a group of battle droids and
coruscant during the clone wars who
supported droid rights
droid emancipation kind of a weird thing
for koresh to swear to but it's worth
noting along with mando's new post ij11
softened attitude toward droids called
out by pelimoto ah
so he likes droids now will you hurt him
give it a once over
kelly's astromech droid is r5 notice
that burn mark
this is the same r5 with the busted
motivator that lucas i was right
i was right he also said
well done this thing ever divides or
buds
i will gladly pay for the office
now the line gets buried by the gag but
i think it's a subtle foreshadowing
hinting at baby yoda's reproductive
cycle that we might learn about his
biological origin this season okay we
see a great
not on the map recalling the way kamino
wasn't on the star maps of the jedi
archives but it was nonetheless there
screw you got some new
we might be revisiting with it being the
birthplace of both of that
and connected to dr pershing and his
camino patch when he studied baby odol
but on the way to the view tuscan
raiders remember this dude sitting away
from the campfire on the far left
judging mando apprehensively that could
be boba fett because
boba fett's thing was it was like a
dragon skeleton tuscan raider item still
in tunisia desert
man there's a rival in the town
definitely evoke some spaghetti western
imagery you can get some great side eye
with the locals as we hear ludwig
jordan's acoustic guitar playing
underneath
one of these villagers is a cameo by sam
whitmore
that's how marshall is open
he wears boba fett's distinctive armor a
backstory originally from chuck wendig's
aftermath books
this weekway bartender is played by w
earl brown
from deadwood making this a kind of
deadwood how cool
you'll remember as the blue that's so
cool
settle down with that beautiful young
widow and raise your kids sitting here
sipping spotska
it's a bit weird when he calls a
bartender by his race as opposed to a
name the two of them clearly had some
kind of friendship in the past
this guy he is the ugliest guy in the
room who has a lot of opinions about
same people
they nailed the attention to detail on
this book with that armor from the
bullet dent on the head
there's a little metal patch on the jet
pack probably to fix where han solo
bonked it you'll also notice the armor
looks corroded
suggesting the sarlacc stomach acid
probably did a number on it now notice
the sound design of the crate dragon
roar
[Music]
well episodes pick up from this
from the original dragon roar that ben
kenobi did to scare up the tuscan
raiders in the first film
[Music]
that is great
now cobb's speeder bike is a repurposed
pod racer engine
similar to how rey used one of these in
jakku and the force awakens
cobb's looks a lot like anakin
skywalker's pod races right it does have
the yellow flaps though this one is red
i don't remember there being any red on
anakin's cobb recounts the night of the
second death star exploding after the
battle vendor and return of the jedi the
hollow projection has this ring of
oramesh text around it if you were to
flip that translate it it reads
little does luke know that the galactic
empire has secretly begun construction
on a new armored space station even more
powerful than the first death star
the word for word text from the opening
crawl of return of the jedi
that's a fun easter egg cobb talked
about how he grabbed a camtono
containing silica crystals
this is the same kind of container that
burner hearthstone kept the best scar in
last season it's the famous ice cream
maker
carried by empire cloud city and empire
the tuscan raider hounds they meet are
massive
we saw these in attack of the clones but
mando is that's where we saw them
damn i could have pinpointed it pretty
similar to the knights of the old
republic where you have to team up with
tuscan raiders and you actually use a
similar tactic to take down a crate
dragon you have to lure it out over
buried explosives
these second raiders march back into
town on panthers in a
straight line a little nod to obi-wan
kenobi's description in a new hopes
and people always ride single file to
hide their numbers
now the great dragon lives in an
abandoned star from the front there's no
such thing as an abandoned star-like pit
there is if you eat the sarlacc this
might explain
how boba fett was able to survive the
sarlacc the crate dragon spews
flesh-melting acid
that could have dissolved the sarlacc
flesh but might not have been strong
enough to melt the mandolin
canonically boba's armor is dirt steel
not best we'll see if the show ends up
sticking to that
mando knocks the jet pack to send cop
flying just like that
this same freaking jet pack
malfunctioning is the reason django was
unable to evade mace renew swipe
[Music]
cobb was right this thing is destined to
be busted and you tell your people i
wasn't the one that broke that
now that way they end up blowing up the
beast
what are you doing that's an explosive
what are you trying to blow the whole
place up
an homage to jaws which blows up that
beast the same exact way
and foreshadowed it the same exact way
ingesting rocks which it's gonna do if
it's chewing its way through sand
it's kind of like how grains of sand can
turn into pearls and clams the final
limit shows the famous tatooine binary
sunset
and both of that two more more where are
all the boba fett sightings
perhaps from escaping that sarlacc and
you can hear some spurs when he steps
[Music]
suggesting he could be the one who came
across thenx shin yeah 100
is he's gotta be they come for i thought
they already
[Music]
boba fett could be living among the
tuscan raiders
masked along with the rest of them he
could have been that standoff
to bring that back around he doesn't
have his arm
he gave it up it no longer serves him
and he might not be that interested in
hunting it back down
but he still could be the key to amanda
learning more about kamino the jedi the
whole
star wars history pretty well
are still strangers too oh and yes i am
wearing new rock stars custom
this is the way shirt available
exclusively at new rockstar's new merch
store but there
is a limited number i think we are
running out but when you buy it for a
few bucks more you can write in a custom
shout out that we will include in
wikileaks episodes
so get on this subscribe to new
rockstars hit that notification bell
follow me at ea boss thank you for
watching or as they say in tuscan
[Laughter]
delightful damn these shirts do look
awesome i want to claim to be eric voss
on a t-shirt that was a great breakdown
we got to cover these sooner i think we
got
really soon like right after we're done
reacting we'll just go into this or what
we can do
is we can uh react to the episode and
then
watch their breakdown and then just take
all their information
and put it in our review yeah and then
act like we're as
smart and as great at deciphering
without having to go frame by frame
because we're just that good it's that
good yeah all knowledge
comes from somewhere and we're just
showing our work okay
i mean i was right about a couple of
things i'd say the podracer one uh
like even eric had some doubts because
even when i was looking at the images in
the review i was like is that
for sure his and then when i did while i
was editing the review
and i was looking at the boba fett image
i was like that looks like tuscan raider
uh weaponry
but i didn't think necessarily about him
hiding amongst the tuscan raiders the
sky's this one but that theory would
line up and and that person's body
language did
seem to be a little bit different than
the other type it seems so casual like a
dude it seems like the body language
yeah i could see boba fett hiding under
tuscan raider outfit and doing that i
don't know how i feel about the
possibility
that it was the great dragon who
defeated the sarlacc
i actually would really like it if it is
more along the lines of him doing
something to jet pack his way
out yeah claw his way crazy thing
instead of
being fortunate enough that a crate
dragon came by
and did it because there seemed to be a
lot of hints throughout this episode
that we might see boba fett we might see
boba fett you go to see boba fett
you know i think they with the way they
scripted this and the way it was
directed especially leading into timothy
all offense
cobb character coming in they knew like
people are going to be expecting boba
let's let's have some fun with this
you know yeah and i wouldn't want it to
just be crate dragon although i do love
like the the attention to detail that
the team really does have like with the
tuscan raiders in a single file line the
great dragon roar being uh brought up
those animals
um that i've already figured in the name
of them but the
ones that were in attack of the clones
it's like they looked familiar but damn
i did not call it
feel bad i hate myself oh yeah now you
have to commit nerds sepaku yeah
it really helps you appreciate two
things like the roar sound and how many
different sounds comprise that because i
think you can lose
elements or maybe just not know exactly
what is score versus
what is a sound on screen you know this
made me appreciate like there are times
when it can become a meme the level of
continuity
and easter eggs that these things have
but this made me appreciate
even coming down to like the r5 unit
with just the right amount of like burn
marks around that one
sector of its you know paint to let you
know that it's the one that luke had and
stuff like that and even
the more fun ones like the crawl from uh
the original films you know being in the
uh
you know death second death star blowing
up text and whatever hidden in the
graffiti or whatever
that helped enhance this truly stuff
like that like the graffiti or the texts
are like only for the people who are
going to take the time and who care
about the languages of the star wars
world
and like things like that i almost have
more
fun with in a way because it's not
necessarily like oh what
aspect of the property is coming up next
it's more like oh cool like you know the
language works
you know it's it's a living breathing
thing even though it is just
entertainment in its own way i mean yeah
you get you i feel like you get more
nerd cred if you get all the trivia down
but i often forget the names of things
constantly and a lot of times it's me
racking my brain to like when the r5
unit did show up i think that's the unit
that luke wanted to buy
but i didn't think that that was the the
same r5
yeah my mind didn't go there which i
think is even cooler to have like a
little bit of attention to detail on the
r5 unit
enough to signify that that is in fact
that r5 unity that malfunctioned in the
beginning of a new hope well it's these
various things that make
me as more of you know i'm not like
obsessed with star wars i don't love
star wars but i do really enjoy
the better aspects of it that really
pull me into the world and this is one
of those things like this makes me
appreciate the expanded universe
and the breadth of everything that's
come through all the movies because of
these
little details that aren't necessarily
the most important they're not
necessarily easter eggs that are going
to tell you what five movies down the
line is gonna look like but they do
really make the world feel rich and
alive and a lot of times you know with
easter eggs and stuff it can sound like
is this
really really an easter egg italian what
impressed me though
was the fact that especially when
they're talking about the great dragon
and having to defeat it and team up with
the tuscan raiders how that was borrowed
from one of the video games
i think that's pretty cool like actually
making the games feel that much more
canon and to a certain extent or maybe
not canon but really honoring that
you could totally see a version where
they do ape from there
especially when you're like exploring
parts of the world that we might not
have gone to
in live action yet maybe the writers or
directors can take the time out to like
well
in the video game they explore this part
and that design of it
was within canon so maybe we can go play
the video game to kind of get a better
idea of what that part of the world is
like and how that might play out and we
could put our own spin on it and
i could feel that being honored here and
i loved this first episode i really did
i thought it was incredible i think boba
fett's gonna play a major factor in here
there was too much teasing and whatnot
to have it just be like some minor role
he's gonna be a major factor
and i can't wait to see what they do
this is a great breakdown thank you new
rockstars this was this was awesome
ah this is the way guys subscribe to the
real rejects please click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever we got a youtube video up hit
that like button subscribe to new
rockstars
while you're at it check out our
mandalorian reaction full length
reaction watch alongside our patreon
yada yada patron of the day shout out
bradley bledsoe we are so sorry we
made it that we didn't shout you out
properly
last month at our patreon uh only a good
handful of people are able to qualify
for the tier
patron the day shout out and then at the
end of every month we make a list of
every
with the video links for wherever if
they miss the shout out they can go to
this video and you'll catch it there
apparently bradley was part of that list
and john and i swore
we had done your shout out we went
through every video
october recorded every single video we
were launching cards for lost
what happened yeah i thought we shouted
we like could
have sworn we did so i'm so sorry for
not doing it because you are
one of like the most loyal reject nation
followers one of the most loyal paid
toronto checks and i
converse with you pretty much weekly at
this point so
i feel really bad for not having shouted
you out
because you earned it you got a great
youtube channel you have great music
you're a wonderful editor we will work
together one day i'm sorry
i love you i'll forget to shout you out
next month yeah
that'll just be your new shout out cycle
exactly the beginning of the following
month
say hi to your wife for me
she thinks of me oh when you guys
are fighting
[Music]
you